[موسيقى]
غير ان هذه الهوايه لا تخلو من مخاطرك
كبيره قد تؤدي الى ان يفقد الصقر حياته
وهو ما حدث واقعا مع رمضان وابنه واخيه
الذين تقطعت بهم الشغل في الصحراء ولم
يجدوا لهم منقذه
انا يعني
[موسيقى]
مرينا بتجربه من فتره قريبه هي كان حصل
معنا حادثه كبيره جدا وتعرض لها ابن عمي
وابنه واخوه صغير كانوا معه في رحله صيد
المرحوم رمضان هو واخوه مساعد
وابنه شاهين صغير
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى يعني ان هو يعني يحصل
معه مخاطر وتعرض
[موسيقى]
في الصحراء
في رمضان الذي احترف السيجاره منذ صغره لم
تشفع له خبره حيث اصر على تتبع صقر دون
استعداد كافر فلم يقدر ما يمكن ان تؤول
اليه الامور في هذه الصحراء التي لا ترحم
احدا طلع منه فجاه طير طير بيحمل ريشه
ريشه تتبع
طير اخذ موجه الريح وصعد ناحيه الرمال
اللي هي المغريه جدا
وهيجيب الطير ويرجع تفضل وراه فضل ورا
الطير فطير فضل صاحبه
فمحبش يصيب الطير وكمل مسيرته وراء الطير
فاااا العربيه زي ما تقول خلصت منه بنزين
على مستوى انه ما يرجعوش اول ما عرف نفسه
طلع عليه الصبح
عرف انه هو مشى في اتجاه عكس اللي هو
انقاذه يعني
الصحيح في الطريق وعمل سهم مخلصين ميه كتب
وعمل سهل باشاره على الارض والتاقه في
الاتجاه السليم والصح ولكن ابنه يعني في
الصحراء وابنك يعني انت انت عشت لحظه هو
يعتبر ما ثلاث متاهات مرحبا رمضان بعد
الصلاه للحاله ان هو ابنه تعب منه فضل معه
بيعنيه وهمم لحد ما لفظ الاخير
بسبعه كيلو
اتجاه اللي هو كان ماشي في طريق النجاح
ماشي هو واخوه بعدها اخوه تعب منه
كمان خمسه كيلو بعدهم وفاته المنيه توفوا
هم هم الثلاثه
لما سابق
وابنه بيمشي ثلاثه كيلو يرجع لهم 5 كيلو 7
كيلو يرجع لهم مش عارف مش عارف يسيبهم
وعايز يشوف اي حد يجيله فيروح مش عاوز
يسيبهم يعني
خلاص
قريب منهم